i'm the chairman of the nevada state
athletic commission
and i've announced that uh our
commission has launched an investigation
into the fraternity charity boxing event
that was held november 19 2021.
the nevada state athletic commission
takes this tragedy seriously
and our hearts go out to the valencia
valencia's family and loved ones
and as i've said we'll share further
details with you and answer questions
and that's the purpose of
this
press conference
uh i have been submitted questions by
many of you
and what i'd like to do because this is
very unusual uh i'm remote and most of
us are
i will read the question
and respond
as best as i can
as you know uh we have launched this
investigation
i have read certain things in the media
and until such time our commission
sees evidence
i will only speak about the evidence
that we have seen i will not
give you my personal opinion
the commission does not have a personal
opinion
and to be clear
the nevada state athletic commission
had no jurisdiction
for this event or any past events
that relate to this i would
say to you
please reference nrs section 467
with regard to the specificity of that
and we're here to speak of facts only
it had been reported by
metro
that nevada state athletic commission
has jurisdiction of this
we do not
we did not
for this event or any past events like
this
that doesn't mean after our
investigation that we may
have jurisdiction going forward
this is a tragedy
this is a homicide as the coroner
expressed
this is
an event that metro needs to fully
investigate as a homicide
and that's up to those that may or may
not prosecute
this homicide
with regard to our investigation we will
look at every aspect of this event
from what i've read
the wane occurred at unlv's student
union
the fraternities
under the auspices of unlv
the president the chancellor of those
universities and of course the board of
regents
they all have some explaining to do
so with that
i'm going to read questions that have
been submitted answer them to my best of
my ability
and i can tell you that in the past
we've done
some research at the nevada state
athletic commission
and uh
these types of events have happened in
in our state and other states
and uh i can tell you that
the athletic commission pursuant to
nevada revised statutes just doesn't
have authority yet as of yet
the outcome of this investigation will
be as i said based on evidence
if any wrongdoing is found
the enforcement of those actions
will be
handled pursuant to state laws
and of course
what has occurred in the county
it's been asked whether or not this
event was
permitted i don't know
a good question we will find out
that's a county business licensing issue
with regard to
having proper paramedics and medical
personnel
which nevada state athletic commission
would have liked to see
we did not sanction this
but they should have had proper
paramedics
and medical personnel at the event
with regard to the referee again we
don't know
we must find out
if this referee's ever been licensed
i've heard various reports that
the referee was acting a certain way we
don't know and can't be conclusive of
any of this but we will find out
also the students
were there proper matches between them
made
we don't know
but we will find out
were the students under the influence of
alcohol drugs
we don't know
but we will find out
so
i hope that answers some of your
questions
um
and
let me just go through please
all these questions that are being sent
to me right now in a very very
unorthodox way
um
so the question is if we have no
jurisdiction
how are we investigating that's an
interesting point if i led you to
believe we have no jurisdiction
uh
we did not have the ability to sanction
this event
but we do have the ability to
investigate
this event this event and that's what
we're
saying
um
fox 5 maddie white says people who
attended the event alleged medical
personnel were not on the scene during
the event
uh
i don't know that to be true or
untrue
so
a lot of the questions that you are uh
sending to us
they're they're great
and we will be extremely responsive
transparent and forthright with the
media
and all inquiries
uh the new york times
christine chung says
if
n-a-n-n-s-a-c doesn't have jurisdiction
i i apologize i'm a little dyslexic so
it's tough for me to read uh what is the
reason for an sac an investigation no we
do
have the ability to launch an
investigation christine
which we're doing
and
what was was
what is
has become a tragedy
what shall be in the future is most
important
to
investigate this situation and remedy it
and make
nevada the gold standard going forward a
better place a safer place
um
questions are still coming in so
we have not reviewed any footage of the
event i've not seen it
with regard to charity events being
required to have permits i can only
speak to the state level and i refer you
to nrs section 467
with regard to
the county permitting it with regard to
the university
having knowledge of this and accepting
and allowing this well go speak with the
university and the board of regents they
got a lot of explaining to do in my
opinion
um they cannot duck hide bob and weave
on this
and uh we're here to uncover the facts
the evidence
that
supports those facts
and be transparent with all of you
uh
let me see we still have questions
coming in thank you uh
so
maddie white of fox5 local
asked what's
our plan the commission
with regard to added oversight
for an approval process going forward
matt that's a very good question and
that's why we've launched an
investigation
to then to review the evidence
based on what we we find
determined the unfortunate circumstances
of what went wrong here and improve
uh
this approval process or sanctioning
process going forward
uh and i can't comment on that right now
i have some personal opinions but
i promise you that our commission will
do a thorough job will be transparent
and that we will come up with
a solution
going forward and when we do uh
an announcement will
be forthcoming with regard to how we
would like to handle this but it's going
to debate it's going to require debate
discussion amongst the commission
after we look at the facts
are there any other questions
this is this is interesting doing this
blind but
i'm going to ask are there any more
questions from the media
i will promise you that the nevada state
athletic commission will again be
transparent forthright
and
will hold
future
press
conferences as we gain facts
and it will be extremely cooperative and
i hope
that those that we ask
evidence from
are forthright
again this is a tragedy
our hearts go out to the valencia family
this is unnecessary
it shouldn't have happened
and that's why we have the nevada state
athletic commission because combat
sports
are just that
it's not a joke
serious
and that it takes this very seriously
with regard to that life safety and
health of those that combat within the
state
so with that i'll close this press
conference if there any questions please
send them
to the nevada state athletic commission
frankie mason within our offices
shall be your point person for that
and will come directly to me as the
chairman
of the nevada state athletic commission
thank you very much for your time this
morning
have a good day happy holidays